[Music]
good morning everyone and thank you for
coming so early to our talk up what's
doing Android studio UI design and
debugging tool thank you so I'm reading
from a new studio working on the design
tools I'm Jerome from the Android studio
team I'm Joe from Android studio team
I'm Ashley from android framework and
jetpack alright and before we start a
little what about project mobile so
you've heard maybe yesterday that
general studio team has been focused on
product model to improve the end to end
user experience of Android studio so
improving Android studio is not just
about fixes it's also about improving
how you use it and filling any gaps that
we might have identified so our tool
chain when it comes to design its
building your layout building the
navigation between the layout managing
your resources and dealing with the
inspection at runtime on your device so
to go through this to chain we're gonna
go through a typical user journey
building the Google trip application and
to start with John will talk about the
layout editor and how to build the first
day out that you see here thank you very
much so first of all we're going to
build the first screen of our Google
traits app using the layout editor so
upon opening the layout editor this is
the kind of screen you're going to see
and here it's just a blank layout the
first thing we're going to do is switch
to blueprint mode as it is faster and
it's just less distracting when trying
to just build the constraints on your
layout and you don't want to be just
looking at what the components actually
look like so I'm just going to from the
palette just dragging all the components
that I need for my layout more or less
in the definite place and once I'm done
with that comes the time to build the
constraints so as a way to be a bit more
efficient building constraints I could
build them like one by one but using the
contextual menus we
can build several constraints in one go
for example here I want to Center the
recyclerview within the layout so one
thing I can do is right clicking on the
recyclerview and in the contextual menu
there is the option of centering
horizontally what that does is it
creates both a left on the right
constraint in one click ensuring that
the recyclerview will be centered
once I'm done building all my
constraints this is what my layout looks
like in the blueprint mode obviously
doesn't really tell me right now if I
build the right thing compared to the
design that I was given so I'm going to
go back to design mode and see what it
looks like and in the design mode you
can see that it looks not very much like
the original designer was given and the
reason for that is that the recycler
view is pretty much empty as you know
recycle views usually get the data
populated at runtime but that's not very
helpful when you're trying to build your
layout and make sure that it displays
correctly with the data that you're
going to see so to solve that problem
you can use design tools attribute so
design-time attributes you can simply in
the recycle of you use the contextual
menu again and the sample data picker
just like you see on screen and from the
data the sample data picker you can pick
one of the predefined templates that we
provide for you for research review
items here I'll just pick the first one
the email client doing that creates a
layout recycler view item for that
result of your item that email client
card and at the same time it links it to
do your recycler view so that in the
layout editor
it shows populated of course we're not
building an email client what we want to
build in the recycler view is those
trips card so I'm going to edit that
result of your item that was created
to be a trip card in the resource
manager panel in the left hand side that
you can see here in that vadym is going
to present to you in much more detail I
can simply first rename my results of
your item to something more appropriate
to my project and then I can start
editing it double-clicking on the layout
in the resource manager will simply open
that layout in the layout editor as you
can see on screen I pretty much have all
the right components right there for my
trip card like an image view couple of
text views but they're obviously not
having the right constraints so I'm
going to start by deleting all the
constraint clicking that button in the
in the toolbar and once that's done I'm
going to just reorganize all those
constraints one issue here is that we
have quite a few confuse overlapping a
trouser
in a small area that can be a bit
cluttered and we've heard from you that
in this situation building constraint
can be a bit difficult it can be
sometimes difficult to drag the
constraint to the right target on the
right components especially when
components are overlapping
so what we're now allowing to do is
dragging the constraint directly on to
any place in the component that you'd
want to attach it to and then a pop-up
menu opens asking you what type of
constraints you want to set it gets
really interesting when you're dragging
a constraint into a location that has
overlapping component in that situation
we are offering not only what like
several types of constraints but you can
also select which of the overlapping
components you want to attach that
constraint - and that should makes it
much easier to build constraint layouts
in the cases where you have overlapping
and small components
one final way that can be helpful for
you to build constraints efficiently is
using the componentry so in the
componentry if you do multi selection of
components like here we selected two
text views you can again with the
contextual menu right-clicking and
selecting one of the constraint
available you can create that one
constraint over the multi components
that are selected so here we create two
constraints at the same time on those
two text views once we're done building
all our constraint it's time to
customize our views a little bit and for
that we're going to use the attributes
panel on the right-hand side of the
layout editor we have redesigned the
attributes panel to show a new section
at the top called declared attributes in
that section we put all the attributes
for the selected view that have been set
specifically for that view so right
there you can edit an attributes that
you've already been set if you want to
set a new attribute on that you you can
simply click the plus button and add the
name and value for that attribute
another thing you can do in the
attributes panel is used a constraint
widget to set margins from your feedback
we've heard that you would like who you
would have liked to see in addition to
being able to set just actual values
like number value for the margin you
want it to also be able to set custom
dimensions defined in your project
that's why we've added that at dot dot
dot option at the bottom of your
drop-down clicking on that button opens
a resource picker where you can pick a
dimension that is that you've already
defined in your project or you can
create a new dimension right there
one final thing that needs to happen
looking at that layout you see that the
image view is populated with sample data
but it's just default sample data coming
from Android studio so that's not really
representative of the kind of data that
your recycler view will receive at
runtime so what you can do is set your
own sample data to that image view we've
added images of cities into directory
called cities in the sample data folder
of our project and you can see that it
appears in the result in the sample data
picker and we can select it to set that
sample data and going back to our
original layout we can now see that it
looks much more like the original design
that you got and from there you can
really see if the design has been
implemented properly and will work when
receiving real data once the application
is running on the device so now we are
done with the navigation with the
building of the first constraint the
first screen and we want to move on to
building our next screen in our
application but instead of just going
back to creating a layout file and
building it from the layout editor we
want to start right there thinking of
the navigation flow of our app and how
the first screen will transition into
the second screen and to do that we're
going to have a look at the navigation
editor so the navigation editor is a
visual tool that makes it easier to use
the navigation architecture component
from the jetpack library the way to
navigation architecture component works
is it relies on having a navigation host
fragment as the main layout in your
application so here in our activity main
layout file we're going to drag from the
Navi
from the layout editor palette enough
host fragment it's there by default and
we're going to drag it onto the design
surface when doing that it will ask you
to select a navigation graph associated
with that nav host fragment if you
haven't already created a navigation
graph you can do it right in that dialog
which is what we're doing and this is
what your layout will look like it's
empty I mean there's just this now host
fragment because the navigation editor
the navigation architecture component is
the one that's going to populate it with
the various fragments that you're going
to load but double clicking on it will
open the navigation editor and this is
what a navigation that it looks like
when it's empty
first thing we're going to want to do is
add our first screen as the starting
destination for up in the add
destination menu you have pre-selected
all the layouts that exist in your app
so for us we're going to just select
that fragment welcome which is the
layout who have been working on
previously and set it right there next
we want to select to add the second
screen but because we haven't created a
layout for it already we can simply
create a new destination from the
destination menu and doing that will
offer you the possibility of creating a
new fragment class and its associated
layout and that's the layout that's
going to be used as the second screen
once the two screens are in the
navigation editor comes the time of
linking them together and that can be
done with actions so you can simply
create an action as shown on screen and
in addition you can directly in the
attributes panel of the navigation
editor set some of the properties for
that action like what animation will be
played when transitioning through
reduction or pressing back
another very interesting thing that can
be done with action is past typesafe
data from one screen to the next if you
want to do that you can on the receiving
destination click the plus button in the
argument section of the attributes panel
and that opens a dialog where you can
simply specify the name of the argument
and the type of the argument that can be
a type that's pretty fine or that can be
a type that you defined in your project
for whatever object you want of course
building the navigation graph is not
enough to fully specify the navigation
of your app you also need to write a
little bit of code but it's pretty
simple as you can see here I'm just on
the item of the recyclerview for the
onclick listener I want to transition
and go through that action so what I do
is I create the action object passing it
the argument that I specified in the
navigation editor and once I have the
action I can simply call the navigate
method of the navigation library to
actually perform that transition and
that's all you need to actually do the
transition you defined one final thing
you can do in the navigation editor is
use placeholder to fill the rest of your
navigation flow if you don't want to
bother at that moment creating new
fragments and later on when you're ready
to do so you can simply go back and
replace them with layouts so I think now
it's time to actually build our second
layout and as you can see it's a layout
that involves a lot of images and a lot
of resources and we're going to see how
the resource manager can help us build
it so I was talking before about filling
gaps and one gap that was existing in
Android studio was how to manage
resources so let's go to see what the
issue where the Android studio a
resource directory structure is made for
the framework not really for the user
because when you get
resources from your designer it might
look like this you might have been
shunned folder I'm sorry I'm just
the other issue first is that in Android
studio you don't have any thumbnail view
of all this specific Android view so
layout vector rubber or shapes the only
way you can preview this are is to
double-click on one layout on one file
and see it in the preview so to solve
this problem we've introduced in Android
studio 3.4 the resource manager which is
a new tool that helps you import use and
explore your resources in a more
graphical way to open it simply click
the button resource manager right below
the project button on the left side of
another studio and it will open this
neutral window one more time so back to
our program on the left side we have our
structure our project structure on the
right side we have what the designer
gave us so we can see the different
program on the file that the designer
gave us maybe they use their favorite
design software and use a default export
option and it might be missing the
drabble prefix on the folder names or
maybe they use the web format with the
suffix like add to X and what you would
need to do is to really remove the add
to X a fix and then copy/paste every
single file one by one the other issue
is the folder might be missing and you
would have to jump back to the
documentation to remember what the
qualifier for this specific folder where
and you have to put them in the right
order how does it work with a resource
manager now you can simply drag and drop
the whole bunch of file that you've
brought onto the resource manager and
they will be automatically imported and
grouped by name so as you can see here
our resources are grouped by name and
the right qualifier have been applied so
what just happened here thank you
if we identify a qualifier we could it
could be web or Android in your file
path like here we will simply create the
corresponding android folder and strip
strip out any suffix that might be
present in the file and copy it onto the
interior project of course if you want
to add more qualifier for example
randomly a local and random language
like French and region friends you can
split do it here and you don't have to
remember the order or create manually
the folder it will be created
automatically for you with the right
qualifier you can also rename your file
as if you want to at this point no our
resource are grouped in the resource
manager and you can see them all in one
go so you will see only one version of
your resources by default but when you
double click on the resource you will
see all the different version with the
qualifier the different qualifier
applied on it and the file type if you
were to analyze like what file word
taking the most space on your
application no this is a feature I'm
really excited about you can no drag and
drop your SVG and there will be all
converted at once into a vector Bravo
so here I have a my file picker open I
don't need to select anything I can
simply click open and all my is VG will
be imported and converted another really
cool feature is proving all your layout
it might be hard just freaking I tweak
of magazine layout by name so when you
open the recess manager on the Layout
tab you can see all the layout and with
way easier to find the one you're
looking for
so as I was saying before we have a tool
chain I want to integrate this whole to
chain together so what we did is
integrate integrated tightly with the
layout editor so for example here I have
a layout that I want to include so the
top part I can simply drag and drop this
lay out onto the leggett editor and it
will create an include view and the same
apply for trouble drag and repairable
and the image view will be created so
let's just go fast forward to the end of
this view alright so now we can see that
on the previous layout our toolbar is
not the right color so what we can do is
open the color tab and see all the color
that are defined on our project and you
can simply double-click on one of them
and it will move open the file and move
the cursor where the color is defined
then you can use a new color picker to
choose your to choose visually choose
the color the color picker works in LGB
and HSB if you were to work with it with
a designer that choose htsb value or you
can use the material palette that is
already there so know how to layouts
already and want to run them on the app
so we're gonna welcome back Ashley and
Joe to tell us about inspecting your
layouts
thank you for deem so now we're on to
the next part of the development cycle
where we actually get to run the app see
how it works with real data and make any
adjustments that we might need to now
today if you want to see how your
layouts are working at runtime
there's the layout inspector tool in
Android studio layout inspector gives
you a snapshot of the complete view
hierarchy of one screen and some
information about the attributes that
are set on each view but right now it
has a number of limitations and this is
due in part to what data the android
framework makes available to studio to
show now in android q the framework has
added a number of new api is for studio
to use to expose more view and layout
debugging information in studio ashley
is going to talk about those new api
shortly now to verify the framework
additions are sufficient for us to show
the information that we want to to the
users a couple of us from the Android
studio team have taken a little bit of
time out from our project marble work to
adopt the new api's and see what we can
do with them and we've started work on a
completely new layout inspector what I'm
going to show you now is a sneak peek of
the work that we've done so far now this
is early work it's not yet in the latest
preview builds but as Chad said
yesterday and the developer keynote we
love previews we love developer feedback
and so we're going to get it out into
your hands as soon as possible now let's
see how it works well start with the
google trips app that we've been working
on and you can see now that it's running
in the emulator and we've hooked things
up so that it's running on real data
from a user rather than the sample data
that we were using at design-time now as
we scroll down here you can see that
some of the trip descriptions in the
real data are significantly longer than
what we had in sample data to a point
where the text is sort of dominating the
images in a way that we hadn't intended
let's take a look at this in the new
layout inspector
you can see that the new layout
inspector gives us a view similar to
what we have in the layout inspector
today if we select the textview in
question here and then look at the
attributes panel on the right we can see
that there are a few differences
compared to what we have in the current
layout inspector first of all we have
the actual attribute names here whereas
previously we had a collection of getter
methods that may or may not have
correspond it very well to the actual
attributes they should make it much
easier for you to map back from what you
see here to what you have defined in
your own layouts and styles secondly we
have nicely formatted attribute values
for a number of different value types
and we couldn't always get that before
so for example you can see we have an ID
an enum value a color etc thirdly we
have some information now about where
that value is being set so you can see
that we have this declared attribute
section here similar to what we have in
a layout editor for those attributes
that are set directly on the view that's
selected now let's look at the relevant
attribute here at exercise once we have
the selected you can use your preferred
navigate to declaration keystroke to go
directly from here to the layout XML
where that value is being set let's
change it to make a little bit smaller
now as you heard in the developer
keynote in Android studio 3.5 preview we
have this new apply changes
functionality and you can hear more
about that right after this in the
what's new in Android developer tools
talk but right now we'll use it to see
our change in the emulator without
having to redeploy our app and in fact
we'll see the update right away in the
new layout inspector as well and this is
because layout inspector is mirroring
what happens on the device live so if we
were to scroll back up here would see
that the layout inspector Scrolls right
along as well
let's take a look at another scenario
let's say we want to implement a dark
theme for our app now here you see we
have a light background color let's find
out where that background color is
coming from if we look in the fragment
XML we have here we don't see it set
there directly let's take a look and
layout inspector so if we select the
background here you can see if you can
see really well that we don't have the
background color set directly on this
view now why might that be well we've
only selected the topmost view here and
the background color might be set
somewhere lower down in the view
hierarchy but which view is it being set
on well the new layout inspector gives
us an easy way to find out
so in the 3d view it's easy to see which
view is drawing what here now if we
select that view you can see that the
background color is indeed being set but
in what file is it being said it's not
in at the top and the declared
attributes section so we know it isn't
being set on this view directly but
again if we select the property in the
attributes panel we can navigate
directly from there to where it's being
set and in this case it's being set in a
style and we can navigate directly to
that style even if it isn't referenced
explicitly by your view this 3d read the
3d representation we saw allows us to
visualize things in other ways as well
and we're SELEX plural here so for
example it might be useful to just focus
on one view and it's children or it
might be useful to group views together
based on what layout file they're
defined in so example for this screen
you can see that at the top we have the
recycler view items and then the
fragment and then the activity and
behind that the various views that are
defined by the framework we have a lot
more plan for the Lite new layout
inspector and I'm excited to see what we
can come up with now to talk about the
framework changes that were needed to
enable this here's Ashley thanks Joe
so for Android q we've added three new
api's to enable these new inspection
features we have the ability to take all
the drawing commands current that went
into building a frame on the screen and
serialize them and send them back over
to studio so it can replay them and
build that lovely 3d view we
significantly sped up how long it takes
to get the properties of views in the
view hierarchy as well as adding
additional metadata to that and making
it more correct and we added some new
api's to the resource framework that let
us see where an attribute value came
from as well as some more insight into
the decision process of which themes
were applied when reaching that
attribute value so to talk about the
skia picture skia is our 2d graphics
library that underlies the UI toolkit so
this is a simplified view to actually
fit it on the slide but it's a list of
drawing commands that go into building
one of our trip cards from earlier so if
we look at it's composed of shadows
rounded rectangles images text all of
that along with the meta along with the
assets needed to render it the image
data the font data etc and we get this
from skien natively it's very quick it
allows us to do our live preview because
we can get this well a few times a
second and it's generally very small but
the problem with this is if we want to
zoom in on the switch here it's composed
of a text a rounded rectangle and a
little image for the circle slider
switch and we don't know which views
those came from there just drawing
commands so we wanted some way to group
drawing commands by what view they came
from so we look at the render node API
which is a organization tree that
underlies both views and draw bowls and
we add a unique ID to each render node
we then exposed this unique ID on the
views and annotated the skia picture
itself with where each render node
started and stopped drawing this lets us
when this lets us on the studio side
walk through and see where AV started
and where it stopped and associate these
three drawing commands back to the
switch view additionally since we have
start
stop we have a nice nested framework
kind of like HTML that lets us see
here's all the drawing commands again
simplified that went into building this
card view as long as well which views
they start and stop from which what's
this do nesting so let's talk a little
bit about how we fix property inspection
to Joe's point earlier where everything
was get her names or method names that
was because we are using reflection at
runtime on the attributes inside the
view instance and reflection isn't the
fastest thing in the world especially on
a mobile device and I would for a very
complicated app that could take up to
several seconds to render an entire view
hierarchy so we look into a approach of
you know we have a method that she
realizes everything that gets a little
brittle if you add a new attribute to
your view it's not updated so we added
in any annotation processor which allows
us to retain the flexibility that the
reflection provided us all you have to
do is add an annotation if you add a new
getter so let's take a look at what that
might look like for a custom view
because this will be relevant for anyone
who's building library view soon so we
have a color view it's a property as a
color and we annotate it with
inspectable property and this gets us
when the annotation processor looks at
it this gets us a little bit more
context than we had before of just
looking at the gutter so we're in Kotlin
and we can see the at color int
annotation as well as the integer type
which we know that we've packed a color
into the center and it's not just a
numerical value and we've we got the
name of the property which we can use to
make inferences about its attribute ID
what to call it and of course we can
override any of the inferences using
properties on the annotation itself so
what the code generation for this looks
like is it builds a companion object
that will sit alongside this view so
let's take a look at what one those
might look like so this is an inspection
companion it's a new API for queue and
it has two purposes one defines a list
of Giffen a class here the properties
defined on that class so in this case
we've defined color
if you look into the call to map color
please we have the type there since it's
a color we have the property name color
and we've inferred the attribute I've ID
off our adder this will also enable us
to if you didn't have an infrared
attribute ID or you supplied one we
would put it in there this teaches the
studio if I have of you here's what I
here's what properties I have on it and
here's what there attribute IDs are and
this allows us to name well that part of
that jump to code completion function
the next step is when we actually have
an instance of the view we want to read
the properties so again it since our
view is defined in Kotlin and we're in
java because this is generated code we
call via get color we have a direct call
to the getter no reflection required
it's very fast and this enables us to do
the live updating of the view hierarchy
in studio because we do not have all the
additional overhead we did previously so
we're all that gets us is to a current
value so we can say here's a this lovely
blue text color we have here we can say
what it is regardless of whether it was
set in run time maybe you called V dot
set color or if it was set in resources
but most attribute values are set in
resources so we wanted to help with that
case so we want to help with a case
where in this case it's defined in your
widget so we added an API to resources
that lets you say I've gotten this value
tell me where it came from we tracked
that data and we store it through the
entire resources framework
additionally we wanted to get some
insight into how Styles affected this so
the resources framework when it's
resolving an attribute value has to make
a decision about which style to apply so
we took the decision tree and we added
an API to expose that
so it's essentially the list of styles
that were considered while but
eventually maybe used or not used while
resolving that attribute value the
problem with all this is its ephemeral
because views once they've been inflated
they forget their relationship to
resources so once they've been
constructed they don't remember where
they
came from for the most part so we had a
developer option that allows views to
store both their the map of attribute
IDs and locations where they came from
and the sorry the at the style of
resolution stacks from the themes on the
view lets studio when it's ready or
you're interested you want to drill down
more into a property come back to a view
and ask the view hey where did your
attribute values come from and what are
their styles so that pretty much wraps
up everything we have for Kiel and I'd
like to welcome that image room back on
the stage to wrap us up so you've heard
about the whole tool chain and I hope
you're gonna be using it when you come
back home so is building your layout
with the layout editor and the new
feature we've added building your
navigation with a navigation edit or
managing resource with a resource
manager and doing you your inspection
with a new language inspector this year
io is packed with Android studio talks
right after in the amphitheater
you can watch the what's new in Android
development tools presented by tor and J
then you have was doing the Android
build system on stage 2 which is on the
other side which start this afternoon a
little red dots here and with studio
tips and trick presented by a curated
selection of engineer and project
manager stage 2 and finally tomorrow was
new in constraint layout and motion
layout by Nicholas M John we're going to
be taking question right outside here
thank you very much for coming and
hopefully see you next year
[Music]